[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
not only were shacked up with one
ourselves hey everyone and welcome to
another game of play for all charity
stream I'm Lucy joining me today we've
got two more and very special guests one
of which you may have seen last week
when he's playing dog souls but we've
got Marcus Fox and Henry Zebrowski from
the last podcast on the left
thank you so much for joining us thank
you for having us from across the drink
we're both in America now oh yes very
ordinary now so yeah time and I are both
up in / Francisco but we thought when we
were planning this stream with you guys
were like what better way to bring us
all together Brits you guys obviously
best known for last podcast talking
about serial killers so we've got a
British game about a murderer we have to
crack the case and it's kind of like an
FMV game real-life actors you can walk
around I from what it looks like I took
like a quick ten minutes yesterday a
very quaint British village again oh is
this gonna be one of those things like
who stole the butter turn in terms of
you know British crimes that's a very
serious one and I'm the saying is
British but the crime is definitely
American in that it's murder
so yeah we are we love to hear
contradiction spot the liar and laia has
an exclamation mark at the end of it so
you know
don't we gotta watch out serious a very
serious liar but today is we are
obviously raising money still for black
lives matter and covin relief Direct
Relief links are on the screen and in
the description please donate generously
if you're in the chat if you have
questions or if you just want to help us
solve the case
please let your voices be heard so
that's gonna be like with spot the liars
it's gonna be like like mafia where the
guy is very obviously lying by going
yeah watching I played some LA noire and
it's like a way you can tell it's like
lying is that if it's connected to the
murderer but then if it's a woman the
cop just slaps her and I if that game is
rough the game is rough that is change
that they needed to make to that game
cuz one of them just goes if you need to
say doubt to someone he just starts
yelling at you even with like a really
polite conversation he just starts
screaming at you yeah I don't [ __ ] I was
like I guess this is very close to being
a real American police officer yeah I
guess so
but this is like a little more subtle
it's not going to exaggerate but we can
just get into it and you'll see very
quickly that it's it's more a case of
like listening to what they're saying
and trying to read between the lines to
figure out what evidence needs to be
presented okay I get to like British
saying because honestly since moving to
America there are some things that we
say back in the UK that we just
commonplace but Americans do not
understand at all yeah you need to
translate yeah all right wait when
someone says chopped what the hell I now
know that that's good
it does sound bad but it means that
you're you're proud excited it would be
weird tough that you guys are on the
stream with us today yeah it's a true
you guys have a scene called walk the
Pug which means taking your genitalia
out at a post office what I am that's
nearby I'm a hundred percent you okay no
I don't know we only spend a couple of
days in London did you walk a pug
you with it no I was told not to old
it's only for locals no anyone can do it
now Wow new rule
try to get the tourism up yeah all right
should we watch this intro intro my name
is Detective Inspector Frederick Jenks
and I've been assigned to a last-minute
investigation into the death of Kate
vine a PhD student found drowned at
midnight last Friday in a lake in the
woods on the outskirts of the tiny
village of Edenton I have a visual first
thing tomorrow morning to decide whether
her death was a simple accident or
whether this was murder
Kate vine appeared to the world to be a
bright confident fun-loving PhD student
with everything to live for
however a history of depression and
alcoholism revealed in her medical
records suggests that in reality she had
become adept at hiding behind a mask a
lab report indicating a high level of
alcohol in her blood along with the late
hour of her death and a lack of
witnesses makes a strong case that this
was suicide but the verdict overlooked
some curious details why was her driving
license found on the opposite side of
the lake in which she drowned
also there were traces of morphine and
Kate's system why did she get it Kate
was known to be a free spirit with a
nihilistic love of danger which may in
part have something to do with a
business course called Atlas which kata
joined and which she had been attending
on the night of her death based in a
large stately home on the outskirts of
the village the exclusive Atlas is run
by father-and-son team Paul and Ryan
Rand both were interviewed following
Kate's death but neither claimed to have
seen Kate after the meeting and both
were understandably eager to distance
themselves and Atlas from the tragedy
this isn't the first time that Atlas has
been investigated Atlas and their
questionable methods which many have
suggested border on
mind control Rebecca
landlady of Eden Tain's village perb the
George and Dragon as yet she hasn't been
interviewed though it's likely Kate
visited the pub on more than one
occasion one of Kate's friends was Emma
Bowman who lives at Eden Lodge on the
road leading out of Edenton village Emma
was also doing a PhD at the same
University but didn't attend atlas
interviewed after Kate's death Emma
seemed shocked and upset insisting she
hadn't seen Kate that night however it
turned out her boyfriend had Samoan
Thompson met Emma at university after
completing his degree around 18 months
ago he went to work at a shop in the
neighboring village he started at the
Atlas course a few months ago Simon
insisted that he didn't see Kate after
the meeting but the sergeant
interviewing him noted he seemed oddly
unmoved by her death which makes him the
first person I want to see tonight it's
time for some answers yeah interesting
interesting that's an immediate jump
very scary I think it's got something to
do with I mean obviously it's got
something to do with Atlas I don't
believe that I don't believe these
[ __ ] for a second you might be right
first of all rest in peace fine ok bye
and bye I'm assuming the read Atlas
Shrugged and that's what everything is
all Rand and Atlas yeah you might you
might find the reason to that if we get
far enough there is an explanation yeah
work out here yeah most it the main
detective like you'll see more and more
but maybe you can tell me if you feel
the same but he's got like mannerisms
and speaks the same way that pee-wee
Herman kind of does and it and I I do
not like pee-wee Herman I find him to be
intensely creepy whoa that's very
controversial because we don't
understand pee-wee Herman
No everyone you guys don't like peanut
butter item you might love Peter we're
just were just wary of grown adults
hanging around kids all the time and get
into hijinks with them so yeah it's good
a jimmy savile yeah and you'll never be
the same all right so we've got three
options here and you have any one that
you want to do where'd you want to go I
think that if the last place she might
have been seen was deed so she her
friend was at the pub right and didn't
see her at the pub that's why they say
not they said I would say we're trying
to figure out the details of her murder
we want to find out where the heck she
was that night we want to start putting
together a timeline yeah of did her day
so Lucy if you hit the light bulb in
might suggest it'll give you like an
overview of what's going on British
better do a spot of investigating why is
there such a time limit on this
investigation why is it only until dawn
tomorrow maybe something happens at dawn
there is some sort of weird supernatural
element that they seem to be digging
into or alluding to that's cool maybe
the entire town just explodes at dawn so
where do we go
going up the North going we'll go right
up the North Lane where does that take
us does that take us through the
boyfriends house it looks like yeah so
it seems like the map says so what was
the the lightbulb suggestion Simon and
Emma so on the map it does say Simon and
Emma there so maybe we should unless you
guys suggest otherwise we should go and
chat to them I think we should chat sit
down yeah I think so I think they
they're down here yeah Eden Lodge
Oh Oh life's pointed but-- wait so can i
oh hang on hand so i can huh man it's
like Sega CD this might come in handy
hmm let's take evidence from yeah why
did you steal a [ __ ] out of a bed that
was a jaunty hat human worry yeah he's
weird vibe him okay so we have like a
little case book - okay cool that's cool
this is yeah just like yeah yeah pretty
even lodge yeah these are just old
bottles and a bicycle we don't know what
any of this very polite knock its
vibration Detective Inspector Jenks I'm
investigating an incident in the village
could I come in and ask you a few
questions please
yeah thank you no looking happy oh he's
checking the Nanshan James James there
was a death in the village
Kate vine I believe you both knew her
I'll just speak to Simon first if that's
okay yeah you kept the pee-wee Herman by
a pro ma'am it's his face if this race
it's like it's the longest the long
mouse
that was very rude he didn't offer him a
cup of tea he doesn't want it oh no he
doesn't want him there no no oh okay
so what do we want to ask him about so
Kate fine so I think that's the first
option which you probably I can't the
last time you saw Kate vine so last
Friday's meeting a thing did you spoil
[ __ ] Oh Kate that would be when we
started atlas three months ago did you
socialize outside atlas you describe her
what sort of person was she
well she's talented she was full of life
you know so they were having sex with
each other they were having an affair he
definitely took her away from his girl a
mood change and well there was the
drinking problem when did you become
aware of that well she would come drunk
to a meeting sometimes defaming your cat
stuff I mean everyone knew but nobody
really said anything so I was just
business management training program for
post rats and used with Jake yeah yeah
Phoenix on air Cree Friday yeah well my
group isn't doing in this Friday but one
of the vertices okay Consol's hmm okay
so oh hang on so we can what's this like
you can select it so yeah so what
happens is you ask them about each
question in the top right or each piece
of evidence and the box on the bottom
left will take the pieces of their
answer and as you get more of the
information out of them you are able to
select these pieces of their answers of
the of an answer and then try and
present a contradiction so if she says
right now he said loss okay an atlas
meeting on Friday if there's another
piece of evidence where he says oh yeah
I saw heard on you know Wednesday or
something like that be like hey you said
this and this what's the deal but so for
now it seems like you just need to ask
about these various things yes so now
this is the driver's license um I mean
how would even know he wouldn't even
know about the driver's license I would
never let him know that necessarily that
we know that up top because that's
evidence mm-hmm also I absolutely had a
fake driver's license that looked
exactly like that one I want to know
more about this cookie jar jar's kids
Cates remains her in there oh no
anything above their license oh that's
my cousin's you know me it's I need to
so you like it yeah yeah and there's no
bus service to speak of around here so
it's really the only way to get around
eat a car loser
worth asking yeah well no I give up to
my friends and stuff
I tried selling her at first but I
didn't have any takers except for James
over at four months perhaps and stuff
okay so he's he's making homebrew and
he's just giving it away it seems for
herbs for her herbs yeah yeah all right
well it seems like that's everything
right so we should probably go talk to
Emma who's the other person yeah yes
follow up questions don't think I didn't
know once you yeah once you once you've
like you can replay the answer but I
think you can ask follow-up questions
once more evidence is revealed you can't
tie him up to a chair with a bunch of
rubber tubes like and threaten him with
a pair of pliers
not yet that's the American approach to
it ah we're currently in the British
phase of it I don't know maybe later on
like we get Jack Bauer is anything
lizards yeah yeah okay so I guess that's
worked worked down the list now this is
her this is a boyfriend applause this is
the girlfriend of Simon was last
Thursday in the college library um I saw
her and we chatted for bit she seemed to
use yourself almost usual self oh just
hate being Kate you know bit wild yeah I
have arguments with the lecturers and
things like that
mm Kate had a drink problem how
noticeable was that well it wasn't at
first but as the year went on she'd be
drunk in the afternoon but I think she
cut down you know towards the end of
college and when she started her PhD
all right now he is saying that she that
so she said that her drinking problem
was no longer as bad and Simon was
saying she's drunk and shown up to all
their meetings drunk yes and then also
she said the last time that she saw her
was that Thursday but he's saying it she
saw her Frye he saw her Friday at the
Atlas meeting were they not together
wait that's something that we'll
probably find out later yeah because he
mentioned groups so there might be
something different there like if we
could I think the one tricky thing I
don't believe you can do here is like
present to a contradiction from two
different people if you get what I mean
you can't take a piece of one person and
another piece of other and be like here
so what they then stories will intersect
so if we carry on going on our yeah okay
oh no if we go to him and then say well
your girlfriend's at this hmm you can do
stuff like that yeah well are you gonna
say moles Emma and Simon are not in a
happy relationship
you can tell yeah she looks tired she
looks tired she won't be insulted if you
said that yeah I think the other thing
is like she's got Kate's got a drinking
problem and this guy's making liquor so
it's gotta be something there did you
know whether Kate had lost this or not
um I don't know but I I don't think so
okay
okay all right all right yeah well great
I guess whose is the bike outside
oh it's Simon's cousins he uses it to
get to work
you know the locks broken oh no I keep
telling you to fix it hmm yeah it
doesn't matter
nobody cares about screwdriver I don't
know except the screwdriver what's these
stuck of bottles outside oh that's what
Simon stuff you better ask him I I don't
know
nice have you got a cry Simon's home
group say no I don't like there I only
drink wine all right why did she look
down so like suspiciously though I'm I
hate beer yeah all right yes straight up
just like beds very suspicious yeah no
I've never met somebody from UK you
ain't spear no okay so we back to Simon
I think yeah I mean it doesn't look like
this as much you can get out of this so
I reckon it might be worth ducking out
in the exit and then seeing what get
used to hearing that maybe Emma Simon
always answers the front door so maybe
if you hit the light bulb we can get a
an indication of what we should do next
yeah let's go to the jetty with a lake
okay swim
I don't wanna see what a jetty is what
is a jetty what is it for honestly I
didn't know what jetty was until I
played this game it's a jetty like a
wharf if I find you all woof was I'd
probably be able to answer huh
differences in our culture's there you
go huge ones yeah
that's the jetties use a screwdriver oh
yeah you got it you got it a lot of cool
video games
I thought forensics had checked the
whole area obviously not very well is
that it you know that's all you can
cover this is Jenny's Boris he's putting
in his pocket so yeah that's I think
that's all you can do here but I wish
you'd keep cutting down there different
shoes on each time we could go to
Rebecca's pub and then hit a pole and
Ryan yeah I mean like I always recommend
checking with the light bulb see see
what it advises know the most about
jewelry oh okay
you can ask did this belong to Kate yeah
that's a good point
so wait we need to go back to Emma and
with Lane
I think on the map if you just hit the
pin it we should go all the way there Oh
what no few more questions if you don't
mind ever seen this that's my old
necklace I gave this a Kate so Kate
might have been wearing it last Friday
yeah well perhaps but I can't see why
she was always buying new things you
know lots of jewelry stuff like that
it's meant to be a burden cage but the
cage full enough oh where did you buy it
I didn't some wasn't secret admirer
secret see that's how it should have
looked it's called a freedom lacus what
if I keep this no no so the necklace did
belong to Kate interesting a spare
evidence bag then we should all this guy
is a waiter he's dead okay like this are
they all croaky I wish no anywhere close
to it oh they stop dude they don't have
the magnifying glasses there's no rim
hats anymore yeah we should check with
Simon about ask him about the necklace
absolutely I bet you he does it in the
exact same way what do you think about
this piece you should ask about the
freedom necklace rather than the pendant
okay yeah I gamma I won't like it
actually you know okay I won I remember
because I asked her about it one night
when we're all out drinking in college
kids got your [ __ ] ass right there
the only new over three months
damn he's on point wait how do I make a
contradiction then so you find the
original piece of evidence that he said
he only knew her for three months the
top one feet so how did you know
Kate was wearing a freedom necklace well
played Henry at college well I knew K in
college but I didn't get to know her
till we start to ask this right
so you didn't socialize with at college
and you didn't socialize with her
outside of Atlas all fattier outside
atlas no good one took him
all right before we get into this bit
just a reminder to everyone watching
here please donate using the links below
Kate better than he's willing to admit
six o'clock Rebecca's working in the pub
tonight so where do we want to go um
well we can check clubs open who wants
to go to the pub you're all over the UK
you used to drink in places like this no
no get a beer and taste it and tell me
what it tastes like good it comes fresh
out of the tap uh ooh the left
restaurant Oh go left to the restaurant
yeah don't do that or don't press the
bell we probably want to talk to Rebecca
so maybe first about what dainty laugh
yeah
Detective Inspector Jenks Rebecca is it
yeah there's been an incident in the
village I'm conducting an investigation
could ask you a few questions please
right
what's it about there's been an
unexplained death locally not sure if
you've heard their student yes yes sir
the stressful news you're married to
Ryan one of the actors leaders yes I
suppose I am yes well I just wanted to
ask a few questions about Kate and Atlas
if that's okay
I don't know if I'll be able to answer
any of them but sure hmm I think
mysterious in a small town
so you'll notice is there's a very
famous British or Scottish TV show
called Taggart and the big thing in
Taggart was there's been a Martha so
they will never say I bet you they will
never say that in this yeah he's trying
to go there's been an unfortunate death
yeah we'll never say it's been about cuz
like tag it in the UK's such a you'll
say it you'll just hear people for that
for God's sake are it's like our law and
order of the when you do that yeah so
yeah we should ask about this stuff okay
did you know Kate not very well she came
in a few times but she was quite a moody
person many mornings when was the last
time you saw her Friday she popped in
for a minute
I remember seven ish well she on the run
I didn't see his she was with she put
twenty pounds on the bar and then what
was that for
a breakage presumably twenty pounds just
for a beard lat well she was very drunk
she just put it on the bone and walked
out
was there a broken glass not that I
noticed but she was a strange girl
[Music]
mmm-hmm have you seen this before
no sorry
so you didn't know if Kate had lost it
no idea
interesting no she's doing a job if
she's a barmaid and not people damn
tools no why don't you sell the homebrew
at your bar yeah let's go play know
anything about Simon Thompson's homebrew
does he make homegroup apparently no we
do buy from a microbrewery but we don't
usually buy from kitchen breweries
everybody I know makes their own beer
it's gross yeah it's never good I
I would never go I would never be
thrilled if I walked into a pub and
they're like I know it's like oh what
beer is this they're like oh god it from
Steve he makes it any chance no he makes
it a shed oh this I am obsessed waiting
them has some sort of meaning doesn't it
I forget what it is now seen anyone
wearing one recently not that I can
remember hmm okay she had that is that
the pendant that was on Kate that's not
that's something else no so that I think
that card just explains what that
pendant was a freedom necklace and then
we have we haven't actually shown apart
from I think Simon I thought the pendant
to anyone else is there anything else we
can actually ask Rebecca I don't think
so I think that's it okay maybe we
should just step outside thank you
cool genuinely think I've been there I
mean that's just it I can't feel it I
can feel the table I can feel the stool
listen my body wants to be in it I can
smell that place yes yeah so in our chat
we've got a few of the last podcast crew
in their community crew and we've got a
few games for folks but people seem to
be saying that Rebecca is sketchy yeah
we also heard a donation from Hawking
for $10 who says ever seen this which is
great so thank you to everyone watching
remember you can donate using the links
below fit or ly and for such years - BLM
or kovat I reckon we should go back
outside okay yes yeah reading the chat I
want to know what the chat says yeah
chat is just like Rebecca seems dodgy as
f hey yeah um it looks like you can go
behind the pub yeah let's go in the park
yeah I wanna go see by the poets or all
the fun stuff happens in American pubs
and in British pubs all the good stuff
yeah and everybody that smoke your weed
that's your have your cigarettes out
there that's go out there that's from
the magic apples man no we do that
illegal might have to whole interesting
there yeah broken window let's game tape
the same tape the firearm ting oh dude
yeah okay
a little note so you're just going out
building yeah you can't go we need we
need warrants in this country oh
whatever
what is an outbuilding is that just a
fun way of saying [ __ ] are you sure or
it can be so back in the day when you
used to have an outhouse a lot of those
got converted and then the desert forage
in the chat someone called first name
says I'm defending Rebecca innocent
until Keowee fair fair enough no someone
else's Rebecca's a red herring
I reckon now that we know the window is
broken so like Rebecca was talking about
smashed glass and we assumed it was a
beer glass yeah not if probably was
whatever smashed a window hmm lady I
like cake I think she's fun I know this
name is a few years old but there is no
way that 20 quid is gonna cover a
smashed window no yeah I think that
Rebecca is just happy like and she does
seem shady but I think she's just happy
that a difficult customer is dead you
know everybody keep saying Kate's
difficult but Kate just sounds like a
blast
yeah she's havin a good time maybe we
should ask Rebecca about the broken
window oh yeah yeah
I love these repeated animations and I
like to imagine this happening like that
in real life so people are seeing this
guy come in the exact same way every how
did the window get broken around the bag
I don't actually know and someone said
two girls were arguing outside I found
out after they've gone oh when was this
last Friday just after we opened about
half-past six I taped over it until I
can get it fixed we don't want people
getting cut and Syria nuts does that
sort of thing happen a lot of arguments
no not really I'm quite strict or not a
mistake
I didn't think him suitable hmm seems
like Marcus was my even right there
mm-hmm okay so no she always pauses
before because when she was talking
about 8:00 she was saying she was a
difficult person yes yeah say in the end
she's not insane it's like she's a big
old [ __ ] like yeah someone who has
nothing to hide would just be up front
with their dislike of someone right I
think that's all you can do here okay
now okay oh [ __ ] so he went into a room
with her also a question left and then
summoned her back into the room and left
cops yeah if you leave here see what the
light bulb says there there are parts of
this game which are obtuse in a way that
I'm gonna try on Village Hall also I'm
in M earth it says we could go back to
Sona and Emma I'd say the village hall
honestly yeah sure I try something new
but it definitely seems like she was
arguing with a woman and that woman
might have been Emma hmm yeah that's a
good assessment is this the village hall
up here I think it's the one year in the
far top right oh no that's Atlas so I
think it's on the way to if you yeah
yeah
oh you've gone to Rebecca's pub it is
confusing
like I did this for like 20 minutes
yesterday wait go along the path okay
there we go
sweet not at all mmm-hmm get you I don't
like it bye things are wrapping they're
nice to randomly find the key on the
floor it is always nice yeah absolutely
love it yeah yeah
outbuilding alright look in not
interesting not ready jinx wait at 8
p.m. can we go to an atlas meeting maybe
we'll find out yeah I'll be all sir I
don't want to see what they do you know
what he kind of gives me a little bit as
Grant Morrison vibes oh yeah he does
sunglasses yeah yeah let's go go stuff
up pub go to the post office walk the
pug yeah yeah yeah yeah what the bug all
right yeah what are you find in there so
let's use the key let's see what's in
that it's a bigger house yeah okay first
cool
why is food just left outside and I mean
this is why people get sick in the UK is
there a difference in their food the
food management between the u.s. and the
UK is really show because you guys have
a lot of stuffs just on shelves that
needs some refrigeration or at an absurd
amount of preservatives like it is in
the US I mean yes plastic in it who is
this Ryan's it's getting weird go I'm
walking around yeah yes everything looks
like junk but it's too dark to tell so
we need a torturing a flashlight yeah it
seems that we can't do that yeah okay
well this was cool that's cool though
I'm dead mass
Oh Oh we wear that to go to the Alice
meeting yeah we do that to go speak to
Rebecca and she better investigate the
woods again there are also things you
how Anna Simon Emma and Rebecca since
we're never Becca maybe we should just
ask her about the mosque I don't know
she can just shoot us in the head can
you lose that game like that like can
you know some questions I don't think
you can I don't believe there's a failed
state I think you can if you're not
paying attention you can just walk
around in circles not really getting it
so are we gonna admit to her that we've
been searching a property without a
warrant
thank you have to we'll just let that
one slide we've been we've been
deputized by the Queen thank you Queen
that's all right for there do you know
what is I'm not being funny for those
words this is Ryan's it's to do with one
of Ryan's methods on the course
yeah well masks allow you to play it
being someone different for a while
students learned it quite liberating so
this would be for a student I think that
one's mines but students do wear them
yes it's just there must be other stuff
we can ask her right I don't think so
what if you say about the broken window
I don't remember hmm okay so I think
it's just a mask that we can yeah she
says it's Ryan's yeah okay later on if
that's okay
wait I still don't I still like that for
this I don't then I don't trust him hmm
so yeah we've asked her everything Simon
and Emma and then we can go to the woods
from up there yeah efficient while we're
headed to Simon and Rebecca's place
Simon Simon and Emma's place please
remember to donate to black lives matter
and covert relief efforts you can see
both links on the screen every dollar
penny helps massively so please try you
can
this was like this reminds me so much of
a cooking show like a weird travelogue
show that I was watching in my hotel
room in Dublin or they went to all of
these little Irish towns and they were
all like in here they make the best
potato Harley like it was like this very
thing but every town looked like this
they're very cute yeah I miss I don't
know I miss like villages like this oh
yeah hurry and see where our little
villages look like but don't go to
Missouri if you really want to see
splendor of America go to West Virginia
go to the coal mining towns you'll love
it Gary Indiana is also from the UK
wanna see what a good little village in
America I feel like one of these is a
trap and the other one's actually
British here is Missouri Mizzou if
you're from there you say yeah yeah went
to college there so yeah yeah we've got
Mizzou ties in this house Missouri is an
interesting place
yes various people in the chat including
a friend of the show Whitney has said do
not do that
right could be say Mizzou hello
come on Tigers let's go that's real
that's real spirit is a Mizzou branded
gaming chess yeah we should ask jinx
about this broken offsprings get back I
was in the pub on Monday a college
friend
oh we're interesting this is the public
Monday night with the friend that was
after the Friday night right yeah did we
ask her about the mosque no no ya ever
seen this before
hmm is that a contradiction indeed does
she do atlas we don't know yeah we
should we don't know because she just
said that she would spread her boyfriend
does it okay maybe we should check with
the boyfriend
he's got more information yeah Mathew
Hawking in the chat says lies she
doesn't have any friends she definitely
seems like someone who doesn't make
friends easily no she seems like she's
very sour
yeah very sour yeah hmm okay so that's
about that
that broken pub window do you know
anything about a broken window at the
pub no I don't really go to the pub very
often I'm not exactly a pod person
because you're not fun
wait he's like a horse [ __ ] now really
just we said the Google drinking yeah in
crash mask we use them some of the some
of the workshops and stuff really well
you you have to say something boastful
or or arrogance you did first without
the mask and then you say it with a
mouse and pointers well it's easier when
you have the mask on isn't it people are
not as afraid to be free about it
silence yeah well it was advertised that
was at my college and to be honest I've
learned more in three months at Atlas
than I did is really he's a Business
School yeah go for it I suppose that
might be useful as a conversational
starter maybe show shoulder that to the
girlfriend yeah more information what do
you know about aqus I know that of
course I went with Simon when he first
went but wasn't really my thing and you
decided it wasn't for you yeah I've been
to something similar so I decided it
wasn't for me she was sketchy she's all
weird no I'm gonna do them the two of
them are where hmm but is this a
contradiction like she's never seen the
mask but she has been to a similar
course well we don't know if they used
the mask and every yeah they said they
use it sometimes so I don't know if they
use it all the time maybe not in an
intro meeting but he definitely said
that he was jerking out of pub not that
long ago after
so maybe I should check with Rebecca
then cuz if he said he was there and she
said she was there we could all see see
what the deal is with them if it's
related to the broken window Henry what
was that I remember something we talked
about something similar to Atlas on a
relaxed-fit episode one week that was
like a business court that turned our
business Cora turned into a cult within
the old beat each other yeah I forget
what the hell it was called it was a
it's basically a business course where
you go and it was basically showing it
was breaking people's barriers down by
like putting guys in dog cages and
having everybody like tell their most
sexual secrets while getting hit like
sprayed with cold water and stuff like
what Scientology does really great it
works good I'm sure that was the same
sales pitch as nexium and Scientology
and all the others it's great it works I
think wasn't that Scientology's line for
a while it works it works yeah have you
ever seen the Scientology channel I
assume you have oh so we Lucy and I
stayed in an Airbnb one Schwimmer an
event and watched it for what maybe four
hours Friday production values unit yeah
the production rate out of this world
they have the what they're saying makes
no sense because it's just a buzz word
after buzzword but they have bespoke
b-roll built with I would say actors but
it's probably just seeing on people who
have members of Scientology they
purposely use people that are not
members so that when they get quick
kicked out or they leave they can't sue
did not be in any of the commercials
anymore off so my wife actually
auditioned for one many many years ago
where she went in to audition for a
commercial and it seemed to be very
innocent but it was in the middle of the
Scientology Celebrity Centre that was
where the auditions were held and then
you'll see that like all of those people
are just being paid as if they're in
some normal
ass commercial where they're not told
what a damn that makes a lot of sense
yeah cuz it was wildly over produced and
we had it on like we were working on
something and I couldn't even tell you
what it was about you know it was is
that same kind of tactic of just say a
lot of words but don't mean anything
until I submit I have some good ll RH
tapes and if you listen to them for long
enough they start to make sense I think
was a point where I turned to Lucy I was
like I'm starting to understand what
they're talking about
watch my 600-pound life yeah that's what
we immediately switch to that and it was
way better
we should once you get the lingo it
tricks you into thinking that there is a
logic because there of course there is
it's all coldly illogical but once you
get the lingo you are convinced like oh
there's a logic to all this and that's
how you start believing in I'm innocent
yeah yeah actually I think my mum has a
copy of Dianetics which I found once and
also what the hell why do you have this
and it turns out that like she kind of
she got it through my grand and I think
went through an event and he just got it
and just like passed it off on to my mom
my mom started reading it and there was
a point when she was like I can see the
appeal and she under the bed just throw
it out we should chat to Rebecca
alright just a few more questions if you
don't mind
so we asked all over the house in post a
yeah yeah what do you know about this
it's an advertisement they had it
designed by natives here think and when
was that last year sometime
hmm so what did she say about the broken
window again let's let's replay that
just think it was yeah it was people to
brawls two girls having an argument
outside at 6:30 p.m. yeah
don't have replay it yeah just in case
sure how did the window get broken
around the back I don't actually know
someone said two girls were arguing
outside I found out after they're gone
oh when was this last Friday just after
we opened about half-past six I taped
over it until I can get it fixed we
don't want people getting cut and seeing
us does that sort of thing happen a lot
arguments no not really I'm quite strict
when it comes to buying cars I don't
think him suitable suitable did he did
didn't Emma say that she was at the pub
last Friday but didn't know how the
window got broken yeah I feel like I
feel like we should try to do that $20
for a breakage and then the 20 pounds
for a breakage and then didn't like the
she's her saying that she didn't know
who was arguing or who broke the window
yeah oh yeah see if then it makes a
contradiction yeah she says breakage and
then says I don't know why we know who
broke it mm-hmm doesn't know who broke
the window there we go
so you said Kate gave you 20 pounds for
a breakage but you didn't have a
breakage that's right do you think the
payment could have been for the broken
window could it have been Kate who was
arguing well I suppose it could have
been yeah could have been Kate you're
probably right yeah but you don't know
who she was arguing with no I'm not sure
I'll ask around
we cater broken the window Rebecca that
really should work that out before now
unless she did okay no it's not just
that you think right yeah we should what
is it what do you think say in Simon and
Eric Emma era what do you guys think um
let's go to the woods see what's in the
woods all right it's usually something
good in the woods at night uh going to
the clearing again oh it's literally
nothing in the woods huh
I don't think that's the woods yes
clearing go to the lake Junction yeah go
to the lake junction that's where she
was found right yeah so Jesse we've done
back into the woods yeah I don't know
there is I remember there being like a
weird option to get further into woods
what's the last one that's the one that
we you went to go back clearing maybe
your clearing yet so we we went in here
but it didn't give us anything hmm
use your monocle yeah maybe I don't have
it use the monocle oh there you go
all right nice my friend with the
cardboard boxes wife he's got a hookah
pipe the hookah pipe doesn't have any
coal on it yeah nothing big set up to
take out to the woods where do you live
what's your name Timmy yeah polite
police officer I've ever seen in my
learning
yeah man yes sir whaling on these day
Ruffman can start attacking these guys
Yeah right on site just start punching
people that's it that's out you know get
results everybody screaming about a few
more things please okay
Pub Omega here we go did you hear about
an argument in the pub last Friday no I
wasn't there you weren't actually to see
my parents
[ __ ] it was yeah I know Rebecca
quite well
we will went there quite a bit after
college huh Thursday night I think she
said she was there Friday night oh well
she said so last locate Nicole -
Thursday
hello skate in the college I were in
Thursday I thought she left to go oh hey
that's a good point when did she say she
left to go home Thursday there's a night
and when did she say she saw okay
okay in the college library on Thursday
okay okay interesting I honestly I
reckon we should go and try and check
out Atlas this is one place we haven't
been properly yet yeah thank you see if
he has anything Wow while we headed over
there I just want to shout out Ritchie
Breck amante how very own who donated
$25 towards black lives matter thank you
so much oh yeah do you mind if I pop out
for Joe Furman Joe no I didn't go to the
pub last Friday what did you do after
the course just don't come here okay so
back
hmm all right well while Henry pops out
we can do a quick plug for our charities
so yeah we are raising money for two
causes one being covert relief
in partnership with Direct Relief you
can see the links on the screen the
covert relief donation link is bit or
lyo forged SGS - co vid and then we're
also raising money for black lives
matter and the link for that is bit or
lyo SGS - BLM we have both the game
sport and the last podcast on the Left
communities hanging out in the chat
right now which is amazing everyone is
very much suspicious of what's the name
Rachel Rachel Rebecca yeah Ritchie
actually says dry hooker which is the
worst which is understandable and pretty
much everyone seems to think everyone so
far is suspicious which makes a lot of
sense somebody everybody knows something
this is one of those classic like small
town murders where nothing can happen
without everyone knowing yeah and
actually people hiding it and everybody
that's the thing somebody at some point
is going to be discovered committing
another crime and that's why they were
lying you're right yeah lie for they're
covering up to hide another crime and
then that crank will come to light and
that'll be a whole red herring business
someone said Rebecca is my girl please
back off which is a weird weird maybe we
should head to atlas well while Henry's
um so there's no I assume he's taking a
huge dump yeah yeah yeah well as soon as
Henry comes back I'm gonna have to do it
as well yeah I didn't mean to thank you
probably be back later yeah I also
realized it but this we did last week
the Dark Soul stream where I got stuck
on chaos egg yeah you know the halberd
the whole time I totally forgot that I
could just gone up the elevator and that
would have taken me back to the guy
where I could get my sword
oh yeah good point
yeah I forgot as well area until later
oh geez
maybe maybe we don't know dog shows as
good as we thought what we did well I
mean I still have to get over there to
ring the bell you got a ring all the
bells since fortress will eventually
take me a nanner Londo byah yeah we
should we should head inside outlets all
right looks chains on this building yeah
weird perfect timing Henry we just
walked inside outlets tiny birds oh
right the atrium right I would have
viewed in the lounge according to the
report that must be his office sorry
I don't want to disturb I don't do
anything just so I would just simply
hello yeah I don't think he even heard
that no okay all right so there's
nothing here yeah I don't always like
those couches they look like they're
covered in butt holes at least someone
does the most uncomfortable couches yeah
they're I hate the thing about leather
couches and stuff is it just I always
wear short shorts hmm so what's really
during the summertime I think I'm just
stuck to them yeah and if you're like if
you're like thick or like soft bodied
like it feels like parts of your like
pouring into those like absolutely hair
no one tells you when you lose a hundred
pounds you just become a human pile of
ice cream yeah just every it fills every
gap that you said it yeah okay well
there's nothing there's nothing here yes
so I think that we probably should go
check out that weird dry hooker smoking
dude right Marcus Jonah Jonah
why is that supposed to be weed or
that just hookah so hookah is a usually
we used to do yeah I think his one was
just supposed to be weed but they didn't
sell it very well yeah because they talk
about hogs earlier right so you bought
herbs
yeah I'd [ __ ] yeah I traded booze for
herbs yeah and you wouldn't call like
the flavored tobacco herbs you just call
it flavored tobacco for shisha oh okay
that's like you lord of the rings' right
that's what the hobbits are smoking yeah
the pipe weed yeah but in the movie it's
just it's just a tobacco it's fine
yeah wacky tabacky as Richard say so
maybe we should go over to Abbey phone
oh yeah you can call the chief if you
get stuck oh cool yeah yeah Dan I
watched I looked at the UM they had like
a big screen of instructions huh go up
ring the bell
all right let's go other steps
hey when you look in the greenhouse
let's have a look at them herb
breaking-and-entering all over the place
here yeah this guy oh what's this
nice very interesting huh witchcraft
this looking glass as a scrying glass is
what he would call it
Oh interesting it's crying glass huh
I want to see them tractors that would
be fun just riding around on tractors
man around everywhere I can tell who who
in our chat is the last podcast run
because there was a few legalized it's
[Music]
like short interval yeah where do you
want to sit Oh anywhere is fine oh you
didn't quite catch your name James sit
there thank you James
Wow cool okay fine
routine you know tomisaburo keen we say
that you all went to college together
you and Kate right right why don't know
thanks guy oh yeah okay sketchy but he
could be a red herring lust
he's obviously weird I remember how did
you know her through Simon his
girlfriend was mates with it so around
college a few times did you socialize
with her much yeah she wasn't outside
all right all right
did you know whether Kate had lost this
or not no idea okay you know about
Simon's bike
what bye you haven't seen him on a bike
I haven't seen him when was the last
time you saw him resentment there it
offered to the [ __ ] missed why Aaron
off like that
why is he avoiding eye contact I'll have
you had Simon's homebrew loser tried to
Simon's homebrew Thompson stuff yeah
I've tried it
did he said it well to me not for money
anyway
Lisa trade stuff what did you yeah what
was this being like lethal strong you
like him yeah he became anime up there
I look through it you look down thing
about a broken window at the pub no go
to the pub you've never been to the pub
oh wow you three months 14
[Laughter]
I'm incredibly suspicious of this small
town when no one goes to the pub
apparently yeah they're all saying that
they don't go to the pub just being like
I know you guys are going to die it's
the only thing you can do here
it's like a whole time that's just made
up of people who went to college
together yeah it's all tell my sketch
comedy service no it's okay
ask him if I his weird mirror oh yeah
after if I seen one of these seen them
around college what do you know about it
not much it's a business course that
Simon is on it you wouldn't be
interested in that sort of thing and you
haven't discussed it with Simon not
really business doesn't interest me I
hate this guy so we need anything about
an argument at the pub last Friday no
[Music]
[Laughter]
argument the pub last Friday no ooh it's
like when you're asking a kid questions
yeah now what's all this stuff in the
workshop paint and stencils and things
like that
oh now he's anime yeah now he is yeah
scrying goes back centuries the ancient
Persians did it this country pagans
still practice it before tea tell us
pretend to do it that's what the crystal
balls all about it's all screen mirrors
just one way of doing it but what is
striving depends who you are people do
it for different reasons not sort of
reasons exploring your mind clearing
your mind
you mean locating with the dead and for
James communicating with the dead and
they make them for other people these
days
and there's a market for these is there
even if they don't believe in it you
make a profit on a very charitable of
you can I keep this keep it thank you I
want to talk to the dead black mirrors
and hookah pipes who calls James is into
interesting thank you yeah man who kapap
since crying mirrors actually go
together pretty damn well yeah what does
the light bulb say we should do Simon
Emma and Rebecca yeah maybe we start
with Simon and Emma all right we got a
twenty five dollar donation from Tucker
Mickey towards black lives matter that
you so much Tucker oh yeah both links on
the screen if you want to donate please
do donate generously okay just morning
tonight a couple more questions what do
you know about James creepy yes Friday
at the market there's a market every
week in sells them no challenge you
wouldn't know I wouldn't but cake would
well she yeah into this sort of thing no
I don't think so
yes she bought one and I went round to
her flat to try it out you meant to see
ghosts or spirits or something it
doesn't work how do you use it you just
meant to stare into it
shall I show you go ahead okay so you
just you just stir so like this and
please put please put something see what
sorry look it doesn't work
hang on so James was selling them last
Friday hmm she went home didn't she Oh
detective Lucy on the case yeah you went
home to see your parents on Thursday
night that right yes but you said you
saw James at the market on Friday
what time did you go on Friday and you
did the argument on Friday you're not a
very good liar Emma oh dear I saw Kate
we're at the pub we were arguing oh
about I learned 250 pounds because she
was desperate and we were just arguing
it didn't really bother me she just
didn't have it on Kate broke the window
yes she did things like that but she was
angry smash things yes
so it was Emma arguing with Kate but why
didn't she want to admit it
in case it gave positive or something
there was there was another
contradiction that I think oh yeah so
she said that she lent her 50k $50 50
pounds yes she was desperate but earlier
when we were showed her the broken
amulet she was like she buys this oh
yeah so how can she be broke and buying
jewelry yeah new jewelry yep jewelry and
things money no what was it really about
we were i green because she was going to
blackmail Ryan the guy from my class
over an affair was having and then tell
his wife if he didn't give her the money
Ryan's affair with Oh Kate no I don't
know I think he was having an affair
with another student and Kate found out
and why were you involved because I
didn't really agree with it I didn't
agree with what she was doing even if he
did have an affair were you friends with
Ryan no I've never met him you just
thought Kate was wrong
yeah she's never met Ryan and yet she's
so invested crusade well there's another
reason she was worried about Kate
blackmailing Ryan wait so is she the one
having the affair with Ryan yeah how do
we she says she's never met him but that
that's what you would say though yeah we
never met right right Ryan
she's what Ryan runs the the Atlas thing
right yes
oh but she's been doesn't yeah so she
has to have ma'am yeah yes which one
went to an atlas yeah
yeah and then the other one would be
yeah you said you went to an Atlas
meeting with Simon yes that's
interesting because I happen to know
that Ryan is the main lecturer at Atlas
you say you never met him
why did you say you don't know him she's
making lick and you can tell Rebecca
either come on okay so the effect and
yes you called it what's between Ryan
and I I was having the affair and hate
you so Kate was blackmailing both of you
no didn't care about me it was part of
the course you see having to take all
these risks she thought it was funny to
turn her back on wine
she thought I wouldn't care but you did
yes I was already with Simon when Ryan
and I you know and I didn't want Simon
finding out and hate thought that he
wouldn't I didn't want her risking it
and then if Rebecca found out then Simon
would definitely have found out and then
it would have blown up and it'll go just
in the big mess so you've just argued
and what while she just stormed off from
broken window and that wasn't it you
didn't see her again that night no are
you sure
yes hmm
there we go like so right laughs REO is
he I think it's time I met this Ryan ran
two faces to face alright alright yeah
go up to the Gregory atlas home right
see man I said what does the air libel
say in his office yet okay see I was it
was it was the other thing is that Simon
and Rebecca okay I want to meet Rand
yeah
very squeak
[Music]
oh yeah you could see he bucks he abuses
his power definitely am i are we an
inspector I just like we're a random guy
who's just walking around with no real
jurisdiction he's got that badge yeah
we've never actually seen the badge from
the front though yeah it's my level
wallet that I'm just so to speak to me
I believe that Kate fine was a student
homeless okay fine
well yes she was it's kind of way he
looks in various ways but I have reason
to believe that maybe rather more to it
than that really
oh then in that case I'd be prepared to
assist in any way possible thank you
I don't like this kind of uh it's gonna
be a lot hotter ask up about yeah he's
got a lot of splainin to do I believe
the last time you saw Kate vine was at
the pub last Friday then you came
straight back and some of the students
is that right yes we like to have a
glass port or two after a long day and
benefits have gone married to the
landlady the landlady Kate okay was a
usual self drunk that was usual it was
for her yes I mean it didn't impair her
ability though she was a very bright
star lots of potential very enthusiastic
orce
what far as anybody could tell yes when
did you first meet her uh when she
joined about three months ago and you
hadn't met her before then well so you
didn't suspect there was anything wrong
do you mean did I expect her to drown
herself of course I didn't inspect her
it's quite a shock nobody expected that
yeah he's so evil yeah I feel like did
British people like that exist of you
her Matt one I mean like this guy he's
the head of a business school that is
clearly messing with people so I feel
like he's a different it cut from a
different cloth I've never met anybody I
know that this is I'm trying not to be
racist but the UK people but I've never
met like a count or a Duke I don't think
so um they're all like I've met some
posh people who have this energy this
like I want to punch you in the throat
energy because of the way you talk and
behave yeah so I can see it yeah it was
quite nice you met who a dame
ok never mad Duke like Jimmy judi dench
I wish I'd met Judi Dench
no this is a friend of my mom's love to
see one and wave at them and be like I'm
from America aren't you impressed
oh no I'm working on your field now
amazing cuz like you can go and see all
of their houses usually for free
these are good offensive and they don't
get any money from I don't know like
where would you get money from if you're
a Duke so they have to all rent out
their houses and like yeah I'm to the
public yeah not working anywhere like
gamestop yeah let's ask about this this
before his iconic line have you seen
this before record you don't know
whether Kate had lost this or not know
about that do you know when an
acquaintance has lost their driver's
license
I never know maybe Kate was like asking
people has anyone seen my driver's
license do you know drives as well Oh
what he drives
um drivers vehicular manslaughter on the
table again come on ask about have you
tried Simon's homebrew does he make
homebrew yeah you were drinking
somebody's home brew yeah he's too
uptight
he's too busy dressers yes it's a
freedom necklace it's a symbol that we
use on the course it's supposed to
represent freedom from the chains of
your ancestry have you ever bought one
of these I haven't but I've seen the
students wearing them now Emma said that
she received this from an old friend
she'd got this from a love interest and
she didn't want to be around anymore
listen I want person yes yeah that's
good to know
keep know about the broken window
Rebecca told me about it I don't know
how it got smashed though I told her to
tape over it we can't have anybody
cutting themselves you have to be very
health safety conscious least a lot of
nodding there yeah that was almost like
word for word the same as her
explanation this hair we don't tell me
they had a friend who used to make them
for words of the course he passed away
last year what does the symbol mean it's
borrowed from paganism it's the symbol
of the Triple Goddess the mother maiden
and Crone represented by the waxing and
waning of the moon
cool it predates Christianity some
people say that it dates back to
Paleolithic times and is that fire tell
me about this by an agency after we'd
spend a week took you weeks inspector I
thought it was a rather grand name
actually if I'm being honest I plucked
it out of thin air one night in the
gorge when I was having a few gin and
tonics why actually somebody left a book
and I
classic absolutely he stole it for a man
right he stole it from her
yeah he's very yeah do you know anything
about an argument in the pub last Friday
what time I believe it wasn't long after
the public opened no I usually leave the
manor house about 6:00
hey this guy's 6:30 I like to get a head
start but the pub wouldn't wasn't open
though huh like the pub wasn't open when
we went at 5:00 yeah okay oh yeah yeah
well fancy one of these before
I believe that's like a scrying mirror
to me we all know anyone before yeah
apparently we were the only ones that
didn't know it's crying I mean you two
knew your birth father bits and pieces
of that nature silly things you know yes
when I was in my teenage years
that's quite an obsession with that kind
of thing I was a very somber child and
not that you could tell always playing
fantasy games reading books about that
kind of malarkey you know you read
long black magic as if not the
chocolates which Satanic rich but you're
not into that sort of thing now cause
I'm not need to believe in the
supernatural inspector the natural world
is far more interesting things grow up
wow that's a rule oh yeah shut up uh is
there anything else
yeah we've worked through all of the
okay we should check with the lightbulb
yeah someone someone in the chat pointed
out I Shawn Donlin says was he filmed
next to a mirror so we know he's
two-faced oh my god that would be like
that would be a very literary way to do
that
yeah what does that say better see Simon
again and we have things we have know
Simon and Rebecca I think if I remember
correctly I remember seeing it a while
back there was something in the woods as
well so we should check out the woods
didn't mean to we get that from the
woods we went to the wood we found James
in the woods yeah we found woods yeah we
got James so we've got Simon and Rebecca
okay so who wants to go what I I yeah
break up no oh yeah wonderful ones in
the worst one huh
nope yeah I'm gonna party Aaron is bail
yeah okay so where we are oh so we can
ask about the mirror have you seen one
of these before
I think so No sweet she's done smoosh it
okay
wait did do we have information about
the now we already talked to her about
that
yeah what what is there a woods clearing
yeah yeah we should go there I'll be two
seconds oh we're back do you think we
should go there yeah what's clearing
yeah here it is ah hello what's going on
here what's it to you well I'm a
policeman and that's supposed to make
what difference exactly it means you do
exactly what I tell you to do or what or
you arrest me no I'll give you a fine
this time so if I do something that you
don't like I have to give you some money
what happens if you do something I don't
like you're gonna give this to Mike I do
not have time to discuss it at the
moment could you just go
oh oh I think was gonna say something
else there but he's guess spit on him or
something
awesome oh what's that what's that the
air devil horns all right we've got
scrying mirrors and devil horns Mary are
these are diehard rock fan or there's
more to that symbol than meets the eye
is there any meaning to that symbol
moccasin Henry I don't know the
resolution on my screen is screen screen
NYX elated so I did not see it so it was
the devil horns that's just one of those
standards like in every single paranoia
or true crime show that shows a
pentagram and they're like this is the
devil and you're like no it's the symbol
for protection you have no clue what
that me and some people think that the
devil horns are just a character in
general just evil yes the hope the whole
thing is that it's 6/6 he's like there's
six there's like three six is it a GU
let's chat - are we gonna reveal the the
affair for Simon I can onus chat - Simon
see if we can let's reveal let's talk
some [ __ ] let's do it dinnertime at 7
o'clock oh yeah he threw his own herb I
thought he got his herb from what is
name Oh
[Music]
corner of his greenhouse to grow so he
knew James well didn't really get on
well it's just through the farmyard
that's back
interesting been there
ask him about the devil horns it's a guy
from the course is an idiot the three
fingers thing is something the students
started doing it's something from the
course the the three freedoms what oh
the three freedoms is from the course
it's a phrase free to be free free
yourself from the things that are
holding you back right things that stop
you being successful
what are they there's a fear of failure
guilt and doubting self doubt you
believe that yeah
guilt ruins lives it stops you looking
forward it it serves no practical
purpose it's basically destructive why
is it getting so mad hmm what you
feeling guilty about Simon hmm
not the most original slogan but I
wonder how far this freedom goes oh it
goes to guide someone you've got three
of your best girlfriends yeah yeah sure
enough he's into a New Age stuff
mysticisms magic spells that sort of
thing
he's nuts though I mean he thinks the
government that's tracking him up there
probably I am they are so we have to go
back and ask James about his
conspiracies concerning the government I
hope so
I kind of want to ask ask that weird
dude atlas about the the three freedoms
and three freedoms all right should we
go to James's yeah thank you guys doing
I hope he's just insane yes he's got the
green house he's got green house right
mm-hmm
man I tell you what though that's where
I beachy
been up dateless yeah we going on that
greenhouse man that'd be so much fun to
sit on a stool who can it down do we
want to go to the other greenhouse first
yeah let's do that must be up the hill
over there step step step step dip boots
Oh what can have the M Cole what's going
on here hubs they all just tray up happy
oh they're just her she's not here but
be interesting to see what he says about
it what is that okay sack a weed but I
can't really tell what they do
resolution looks like yeah look empty
bag oh here we go
yep a packet of suspicious-looking
leaves was found in the greenhouse at
the farm
oh yes asking about you Okin reefer huh
James question here James you talking
reefer and then he's just like no no you
know unfortunately I know that have you
seen this these leaves are clearly dead
and her home smoked let me see how pure
this rephase and that's the rest of the
game you disturbance on his couch it was
James I never understood when every cop
shows it as soon as they get drugs they
put it in their mouth it's like rubber
on the teeth yeah all right do we want
to start with the hand symbol and then
yeah work to the the leaves if I did
that would it mean anything to you yeah
it's a Satanism symbol Satanists use it
or whatever it's like sign language I
love you
no cool using it no everything was that
missing someone local I just think of
League of Gentlemen I would another
local ever hear the phrase free to be
free
I heard anyone use that no what is it
song no I don't think so doesn't matter
it does sound like a like a Raffi song
yeah yeah no a good one could you tell
me what these are please I found in the
greenhouse he's snooping around on the
farm after we it's called investigating
James yeah yeah just mint mint leaves
for cookie yeah oh yeah I heard you were
a bit of a budding chef dabble a bit won
a few competitions very impressive so
you normally just leave packets of mint
lying around
[Music]
mmm you smell it and see if it's mint
yeah I wish you could yeah man I don't
know like I know this is we doesn't
smell like mint smell the dank I don't
know what kind of men you got here this
freaky mint you just leave the bag and
your greenhouse totally whedon britain
very illegal it's a type of legal that
like even the weed that you guys get
it's not real it's in the trunk weeds
which immediately one you become
addicted to it and it messes you up
pretty badly it's like it dangerous to
the point where if you get a bad batch
of skunk we it could kill you
like a - I just saw some pretty sketched
weed and then you pay my way we should
check your nostalgic reminded me finding
weed behind it like I am from my weed
dealer behind the dumpster - McDonald's
in Florida Wow
across the whole the states is it it
states there are certain states it's
completely legal hmm it's almost like
nobody should be in jail for it anymore
yeah agreed agreed yeah like a highly
illegal in places like Alabama and Texas
and and as you know in California you
smoke down the street yeah they use it
as a racist cudgel to find a way excuses
to investigate people from the reason
yes yeah we should go chat - what's his
name again
that creepy cult leader man all right I
mean I've labeled him caught boy but he
could very well be innocent this is why
I can't be a cop
well good thing in my mind anybody who
sits over a fireplace with one elbow on
it sipping out of a glass of port is
fondling children - Jimmy fassl's house
hates here hate this guy
I don't mind oh I don't think anyone
likes poor no I've never had a good word
said about it did this would that mean
anything to you it's a devil sign isn't
it this is on the course it's not
something we use on the course inspector
I don't even know what that could
possibly mean exactly interesting
because Simon had a whole [ __ ]
explanation for it yeah wait is there a
secret society inside the secret society
or my name tell me a bit about the
phrase free to be free free to be free
my favorite motto
well we teach our students that people
excessive guilt
don't they excessive self-criticism
accessing that evils of excess we call
them and we tell our students that if
they rid themselves of these evils and
they're free to realize their full
potential who came up with all this I
have a background in psychology
they're so surprised inspector there's
an intellect lurking in here when we
were based at the village hall when I
say we I came up with the phrase dance
more the moneyman and very successful at
it - oh yeah
oh he's successful he's not a creative
man dance suffers from a lack of
imagination
well no this weed
do you know what ladies looks like
chopped teabags to me what is it I just
you might know I hope he bags this
inspector that he'll do his ask Rebecca
she knows far more about these things
than I do
Oh Rebecca no drop cloth and growing
things
let's go chat to Rebecca by the plant I
won in a way is it definitely weed
there's no it and that's almost now I
feel like there's a whole weird
vilifying the use of drugs in this and
it makes you a Satanist I mean I maybes
pop like a ritual like initiation you
have to take the mint leaves to get in
to the secret society okay so there's a
bunch if I did this why is it mean to
mean something
no no it's okay damn she's so
unimpressed and unhappy you don't give
an F oh yeah she's hiding phrase free to
be free do you mean looks like I think
my trunk madder than that yeah it's
being free of guilt what do you think
about that you mean do I think it's a
bad thing
do you I mean surely if you have done
something wrong that's the point
inspector most people spend their time
feeling guilty over nothing and that's
not a good thing can we tell her about
the affair can we know thing yeah you
can only ask there's no evidence tied to
it oh I forgot we promised that we
wouldn't say anything
yeah yep ask about the mint you know
what these are magic mint no magic mint
salvia divinorum I used to oh yeah it
makes you trip what why it's a nice
endemic and legal quite a dangerous
combination really hold on Simon used to
buy this [ __ ] all the time or trade this
[ __ ] no yeah
I didn't expect Rebecca to know about
growing drugs and if she claims not to
use them herself I'm not so sure
hmm we should off Simon and Emma by the
trading that they did yeah we know you
know you know you hold it while we go
and find them and check them about these
mint leaves
please remember to donate that we've got
both links below for black lives matter
and for kovat relief
we've had a another $10 donation from
Matt Hawking thank you so much man yeah
great and Nawaz Iqbal so today another
$10 donation earlier thank you you and
Tucker is back with another 25 hero not
for Simon yeah let's go Simon he looks
like he's there okay he's cooking pork
right yeah Chuck the leaves in his pork
it was making lamb
[Music]
oh yeah you mean the drunk yeah yeah but
it's not really my sort of thing it
messes with your brain I've never tried
any other drugs either okay so is this
not a contradiction
yeah oh no oh yeah wait soda but then
you didn't know what it is haven't seen
the lead before yeah you know exactly
what it is yeah true
maybe maybe Emma my rhyme out that's not
a contradiction no I don't think so Oh
I said we just go to Emma okay well she
even L like it rats him out although we
could ask the Atlas guy about why he
said he didn't know what this means
where he Simon said that is an Atlas
thing we're not allowed to cross you as
the stuff we hear from ya alright let's
ask about if I did this I love how
swiftly he moves on
do you know the phrase free weights free
someone someone in our chat said it's a
contradiction he said he hasn't seen it
but has tried it is that what you did
yeah they said you shouldn't do
something wrong I don't agree with that
no oh no I think you should feel guilty
if you do something wrong
a cheating no but I don't think you
agree with that either she's a hypocrite
you don't know any chance no sorry I
things like that but you should ask
Rebecca she used to live on the farm
cheek now Oh scathing ever heard of
salvia divinorum yeah yeah
hallucinogenic drug it oh yeah right
wait so do you want to work
Simon contradiction again yeah let's try
it thank you folks in the chat are
saying that it's a contradiction so
which one has tried salvia
but so hasn't seen the leaves before and
then has tracks all right has to be no
maybe not yeah interesting
oh well we should just go see what the
light bulb tells us to do
yeah Oh
Jeff so Leah in the chat says very
pleased to have this unexpected and
awesome crossover between game Scott and
lost podcast awesome very happy
what's that see the woods let's go to
the works okay let's always go to the
woods that night oh wait did I miss that
other path by the father until woods
maybe like near the entrance probably
where they want us to go our sadness
back into the woods these woods are very
is there like one down go to the woods
entrance no I'm the police inspector are
you looking for I'm investigating a
death in the village Oh what ground a
student yeah ask that psycho about it
eros business cult thing up at the big
house
I am Liam Liam condolences reputation
precedes them I think I might call the
station find out a bit more about this
Liam yeah hmm
a likely story Monday sure you should
atlas boy so what is the light say how
much does James really know awesome
coming us actually talk to James yeah
maybe yeah maybe we should do that
few more questions please thank you
okay ever heard of salvia divinorum
James it sounds like a hard spoken cream
was that a pink cream yeah nice it's
about him so you've never heard of
salvia um you're a chef
these verbs all the time yeah you have a
greenhouse yeah Kim is that a
contradiction like you don't have
huntzberger it has to be it has to be we
should ask him about Liam as well just
to see what else he says did you know
Liam Liam who Liam who died you mean
Liam who killed himself yeah he's in my
year on a different course what course
was Liam on science first time I knew
about Liam was when he killed himself
right what you didn't meet him he did
you see that
James degree is in plant science and he
doesn't know about plum yeah nice so
your degree is in plant science but you
don't seem to know anything about plants
so you're still sad I've got her out of
salvia and say that so you have maybe
and you do grow it yes why not what do
you do with it use it for exploratory
meditation and does this involve anybody
else why do you sell it or give it to
anybody else
sure this is for me nobody else and
that's the only drug you grow is it look
if you want Henry Henry does not like
that the only drug he grows not sure I
believe that James yeah he's he's lying
there
because he gave him to Simon T his
herbal tea for Simon's homebrew yeah I
grow it just not grow salvia first
private use only yeah so you traded
salvia tea with Simon for his home brew
some so why did you say you didn't give
salvia to anybody else did you give it
to anybody else
how many people did you give it to did
you give it to Kate no how about Liam if
that's what you mean so you did give him
salvia yes I gave him salvia because he
asked for it but that's not what killed
him but he committed suicide James
because of psychological issues that
probably weren't happy about him trying
what happened okay
so what happened then do you even know
about third-eye salvia
fine tell me then bird I was a cult we
had our very own psycho cult operating
right here from our village hall I got
rid of them single-handed third eye did
they tell you that at the station okay
Oh again they were what you don't know
anything do you look they were reeling
in students pretending to be some sort
of happy life course you know we can
make your life better sort of crap no I
was like unless through this
brainwashing program to make them
compliant and selling them on
on this one path I have help gents
commodities to anyone who could afford
them top politicians famous celebrities
wealthy businessmen you name it
third I were making and selling slaves
there were black-market slave traders
there were wiping people's personalities
using ect brainwashing cocktails of hard
drugs deliberately turning them into
perfect slaves no its slaves are worth
on the black market these days just
killed off I didn't give it down
so you're saying Liam was murdered by
third eye I started looking into it
they're all saying it was suicide but
this is no way so did you ever actually
meet Liam found out and how did you find
out about all this other stuff
stop yes you know where the students you
could see straight away there was
something wrong no like zombies and I
could tell that someone's got ECT damage
or when they've been through mind
conditioning it's just okay so Louis
military use all these techniques back
in the 50s it's all documented you can
read about it screw they showed all the
same signs so did you ever actually go
to a meeting no but how from what people
said it'd be through it okay so do you
know anyone I could speak to who did go
through it look it doesn't matter why
did they close down if it wasn't true
they just closed down and disappeared
overnight after I put all the Flyers up
before they rebranded yeah and do you
think that had anything to do with it
maybe but but it was suppliers at Boston
too close
okay you mind if I keep this come out
third I definitely killed Liam
interesting that was in the list
Wow third question is what's their
connection with Atlas if there is one I
think it's pretty obvious that there is
one yeah guys it's two o'clock Oh No
after the center of the mystery Oh we'll
have to set up another because I want to
know the rest of the story
Lucy save the game we'll set up will
help another session in in a while when
these guys already come invested yeah
well a chat is also like it's super
invested as well some someone's advising
James to lawyer up but which is no name
in the chat is our first name when the
chat is clearly on the bad people side
but it seems like folks want to see how
this end as well so will will will to
talk offline and come to come up with
another time to sit down and do this
[Music]
yeah but in the meantime thank you so
much for joining us yeah look at how I
mean as a team between the four of us I
think we did very well here yeah
prediction we find all the weird the
weird guys like I love it I wish this
game was either like just a perfect two
hours long or that unlike really looking
forward to playing with you guys cuz
like this is a perfect cliffhanger -
yeah you've got brain like cold sprain
washing I'm into it I love how at the
very end of this is hitting it's hit all
the kind of pillars of lost podcasts on
the left like it's good brainwashing
listens to last podcast he's taking
notes the entire time
yeah great but yeah thank you guys so
much this charity organization really
great you guys are doing ready to
appreciate
yeah and for people who are watching
we've got the last podcast crew
community in the in the chat still
please do head tube ly Forge - yes - BLM
or - covet and donate if you can I know
everyone's you know not in not in a
position to donate all the time so you
can share the links around and just make
sure that we are supporting those causes
Henry and Marcus thank you guys
hopefully we'll have you back very soon
and we can see how this go it turns out
yeah but until then if anyone wants to
see more or hear more of Henry and
Marcus please do check out last podcast
and Lucy and I love that podcast it's a
podcast has travelled through a lot of
our friend circles like I know that Joey
from IGN is watching Whitney was here
earlier and we all thought phrase
fantastic and thank you ma'am please do
check it out it's it's incredible but
yeah
we'll see you guys next time yeah and
for more playful streams tomorrow I can
be putting up with the cast of Red Dead
Redemption - so we've got mark Morgan
dutch mandolin and safe and also
cyberpunk tomorrow morning
I'm back because it's gonna be huge
we're very excited yeah it got cyberpunk
up pushed again right it did they have a
live stream tomorrow morning where
they're gonna be showing off more of the
game time and I will be talking work
through the pre pro shows like I made it
I played it but I can talk about it
tomorrow
with last podcast you want it done fast
where do you want them right and that's
that guys are doing and I support it I
agree
sea-monkeys knows knows well the timing
needs I'm still gonna be that day one
yeah hundreds but yeah thank you
everyone
that's a great day we'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]